MODOK is finally in the MCU,
so why are some Marvel fans so
grumpy about it? It's hard out there
when you're just a head in a chair.
Audiences around the world will soon get an
up-close and personal look at the Quantum
Realm in "Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania". As
the new trailer dropped on January 10th reveals,
Scott Lang is whisked once again into this
bizarre and fascinating pocket dimension,
where he's greeted by alien landscapes
and some imposing new characters.
The major villain of "Quantumania" is
Kang the Conqueror, but there's another
famous Marvel villain lurking in the
background in the new trailer — MODOK,
who has long been speculated
to have a role in the movie.
"I'm a big deal! I just fought
Iron Man! I stole his boot!"
Comic book aficionados or fans of the
Hulu show know that MODOK stands for
"Mental Organism Designed Only for Killing,"
and he has a rather distinct look. MODOK is
essentially a giant head wrapped in advanced
robotics with tiny, almost vestigial, limbs.
By no means does that make MODOK a pushover,
and although his physical form is peculiar,
his mental prowess is more than capable of
giving superheroes a run for their money.
MODOK was originally a human technician named
George Tarleton, who was transformed by the
villainous organization known as A.I.M.,
or Advanced Idea Mechanics. However,
it seems as if "Ant-Man and the Wasp:
Quantumania" is taking a slightly
different approach to the source material, and
bringing back Ant-Man's original movie foe.
A.I.M. has already been brought up in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in "Iron Man 3" as
the think-tank for Aldrich Killian.
"Advanced Idea Mechanics, or
AIM, for short. You get it?"
"I see that, 'cuz it's on your t-shirt!"
"Ah!"
Plus, Tarleton hasn't shown up, so it seems
as if MODOK will instead be Darren Cross,
or at least some variation of the character.
When audiences last saw Cross, he was battling
Ant-Man at the end of the first "Ant-Man" movie,
but Cross was eventually defeated and shrunk
down to nothingness — or at least it was
assumed. Now that the second trailer for
"Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania" is out,
it seems as if fans finally know what
happened to Cross after that battle,
as he is spotted hovering behind
Kang as the iconic villain.
When it comes to the nature and look
of MODOK, it looks like fans are
already fiercely divided in opinions of the
big-screen version of this famous villain,
and have converged on Twitter to let loose
a mighty deluge of thoughts and comments.
On the negative side of
opinions, one viewer wrote,
Another fan had some strong words, posting,
This is a reference to Lopez's character Mr.
Electric from "The Adventures Of Sharkboy And
Lavagirl," who also sports a bulbous head,
and was noted several times in fan comments.
On the flip side, there are some fans
who absolutely love the MODOK in "Ant-Man
and the Wasp: Quantumania,"
so what are their thoughts?
One fan of the new look tweeted,
One Marvel fan posted side-by-side images of
the character from the movie
and the comics, and added,
With the deluge of comments that are both
for and against this new version of MODOK,
it will be interesting to see what
opinions look like when "Quantumania"
finally premiers and the dust settles
on the divisive giant floating head.